the mother of a child who i do not have
in class
set up a parent-teacher conference so
she could meet me to ask me on a date
[Music]
this was about four or five years into
my teaching career and thus far i'd only
been teaching fourth grade but the
school i was at had an opening
for a kindergarten teacher position if
we know anything about kindergartners
everything is so
new and wonderful and exciting to them
anything from their lunch that day
to the birth they see all the way to
parties or as my class called it
tooting so the way i would do my
mornings in my kindergarten class
is i would have our morning meeting we
go over our abc's
today's date the numbers all that good
stuff and
end it with a nice morning reading time
they would always sit on this huge
colorful rug in front of me and they sat
in their assigned seats
and every now and then you know
something would happen where one of them
would fart
and everyone would like smile at each
other
well this day i was just so into my
reading and i'm so excited
into my book as i'm turning the page i
lean a little bit
and i yes miss stanley farts
and it's a pretty big fart too it's
nothing small that can just be covered
up right
so immediately when it happens i know
it's so loud that the kids hear it too
and i immediately think uh oh we gotta
cover this up so i said oh who
did that ooh just to save myself
and all the kids kind of look at each
other and they start pointing at each
other you know and they're like no i
didn't do it i didn't do it and so
i just said so remember that if you have
something whenever you need to fart just
go over in the corner so we don't have
to deal with the smell
or the sound of it and one of the kids
raises his hand and he says
yeah miss stanley that's a great idea i
think you should follow that rule too
the whole thing in my mind to get my
students to
not know that that was me who farted uh
completely crumbled
i think a few of them realized it was me
especially the student who said that but
some of them still
you know to this day are probably like i
wonder who that was nameless to say
pretty embarrassing
i teach first graders and just like when
i was in first grade my
favorite part of the day would be recess
it's just one of those times today that
everyone looks forward to i look forward
to it of course because
it is my break time my time to rest to
relax
of course when we go outside though the
students always challenge me to erase
some of the students in my class are
saying miss brown miss brown
let's race let me beat you in this race
my response
every day is no i'm tired go play with
your friends
i would either have my dress shoes or i
just wasn't in the mood
well this particular day i had an old
tinny shoes i was in a
great mood this time when they asked me
to erase
i mistakenly said yes i accepted the
challenge i was ready to go
so we had a student come over to say the
ready set go
they wanted it to be as fair as possible
well i wasn't nervous because
my legs are longer than theirs i played
tennis before
i knew that i still had some gumption in
me well
no we start the race the student says
ready
set go we start running we start running
i have forgot
that the reason i wore my old timmy
shoes that day
is because it had been raining a lot for
the past
week and a half so i'm racing i'm
running of course i'm ahead i'm looking
back making sure that they're good
as i'm looking back i turn to the side
realize that i'm going straight forward
into a mud pile
the students have kind of veered off
from it right dab
in the middle of it the mud is
everywhere the students run over they're
like are you okay
are you okay of course i'm looking over
there's mud all over me
all over my clothes it was just one of
those moments where
you just wish that everything would stop
and you could just
turn back time if i had said no i got up
dust myself off showed them you know no
matter what happens
you keep it moving keep pushing forward
it'll all be okay
but i did not race for the rest of that
year
let me start off by saying i am a very
good teacher so on top of being named
one of the most
influential educators in america i was
also named one of the 25
fittest celebrities in the world by
men's fitness magazine which i'm not and
i was also named the
sexiest teacher live by people magazine
as you can imagine
those titles have led to some
uncomfortable moment so this one day
at a parent-teacher conference you
usually get a letter in your mailbox
that tells you you have a parent-teacher
conference and this is the parent this
is the child so i went and signed in in
the morning as i always do i
looked i got this note i didn't
recognize the parent's name but for the
most part
sometimes obviously our students have
different last names than their parents
so that's fine i also didn't recognize
the student's name and in fairness it
was probably the third week of school
so i kind of looked at it as okay well i
mean i obviously have to have the
students maybe he goes by a different
name maybe i know him by a nickname
so that's why i didn't recognize his
name so i didn't think anything of it
time comes from my conference i go into
guidance where we have them
i sit down i meet the mother and we're
talking she's asked me questions she's
like oh mr froney you know heard so many
great things about you and i'm like
that's great it felt like more like she
was interviewing me than it was a
parent-teacher conference so i said i'm
like
mrs so-and-so i'm like just so you know
i'm like i'm sorry to apologize but i
don't recognize your son's name what
class does he have me like what period
class is he in of mine and that's when
she said very simply oh you don't have
my son in class you don't you don't have
him he's a junior here but he has a
different teacher and i was like well
then why did you want to meet with me
she's like i just wanted to meet you
she's like i heard so many things about
you i just actually just wanted to meet
meet mr ferroni she was like i was
curious
are you single and i was the time and
she's like well if you want i would love
to either
go have drinks with your glove dinner
she's like well here's my number if you
change your mind so she actually gave me
her number the mother of a child
who i do not have in class set up a
parent-teacher conference
so she could meet me to ask me on a date
and again as flattering as
as it was it was my prep here and i just
thought it was so inappropriate and so
awkward to do it during that time period
prep periods are valuable
[Music]
[Music]
you